all right let's get to audience
questions for the week there are some
good ones hey David can you talk a
little bit about how Democrats can
appeal to rural and farm voters so this
this is a great question because it it
is connected to a lot of issues that in
2016 ultimately swung the election from
hillary clinton to donald trump
electoral ii if not in the popular vote
it's important to understand the context
here in the United States where the
geography already favors Republicans
there's an urban rural divide where when
we've interviewed professors who are
experts in in districting they've
explained that even if you account for
gerrymandering or if you fixed partisan
gerrymandering the way that the
electoral vote system works in
combination with the fact that there is
an urban rural divided urban voters
tending to be more on the Left rural
voters tending to be more on the right
you would still have a systemic
advantage under the electoral vote
system for Republicans even if you fixed
of overtly partisan gerrymandering and
that's why we have to have a more
nuanced analysis of this there's no
question that Donald Trump's policies
particularly trade policies have been
hugely damaging to farmers and yet
farmers still widely support Donald
Trump some are abandoning him we'll see
if any actually vote in a different way
in 2020 but by and large it's a
community that still supports Donald
Trump and what that tells us what we
have to understand is that the
urban-rural divide and appealing to
rural and farm voters by democrats is
bigger than just a list of policies like
if you just go talk to these
conservative farmers and say here's how
I would fix the Trump trade policy and
here's how it would be good for you
they're not just going to say oh that's
a good point I'll vote for a Democrat
instead of a Republican this time around
this is a cultural divide that exists in
many ways in one sense social issues
like abortion LGBT stuff race black live
matters and Tifa the war on Christmas in
one sense that stuff matters a lot to
some of these rural voters and they want
to feel like they have someone on their
side but what I think is important to
understand is that while there's a big
cultural component here and there is a
group like for example evangelical
Christians where it's just what
your position on abortion that is all
that matters and Trump claimed the
correct position as far as they're
concerned even if it's transparently
unbelievable and he ultimately got the
evangelical Christian vote the the
important thing I think for the left
understand is that they need to see us
as at least putative ly on their side to
some degree but it doesn't have to be
100% it just needs to be someone who's
not going to sort of flaunt the most
particular or acute cultural
disagreements right in their face so if
you can display as a Democratic
candidate a general sensitivity to the
values of rural voters but you're on the
same page economically that may pull in
a lot of these rural and farm voters now
you're not going to bring everybody over
or nearly everyone but these are
elections that by and large are won
around the margins Hillary Clinton
ultimately lost because of 77,000 votes
in three states so if you hear me saying
if you don't insult or rural voters with
social stuff and you are sort of on the
same page economically they'll vote for
you well know most of them still won't
but the point is we don't need them all
to vote for us we just need some to say
even if we're not exactly on the same
page socially and culturally I respect
the economic policy and my situation is
such that that's what I need to focus on
in choosing who I vote for this time
around there's probably a way even to
appeal to environmentalism that would
appeal more to a rural voter maybe
related to hunting and fishing and
resources for farming I'm thinking out
loud here can we deal with healthcare in
a way that will relate to the rural
experience few providers in many cases
difficult for people without ready
transportation access to physically get
to where the care is because it's often
very far gun control is definitely a
question mark I don't know how the left
that cares about gun safety deals with
guns for the rural community in a way
that will will resonate but maybe you
just stay away from that issue to some
of the grease but thinking strategically
an Elizabeth Warren in purse
is really good at this stuff it's
unclear whether you know it remains to
be seen whether at the national level in
debates it would work just as
effectively I'm not saying it would or
wouldn't but she is very good at meeting
with Midwestern and red state voters the
fact that she's from think Oklahoma
lived in Texas for a while probably
doesn't hurt and she is able to relate
to these rural voters on the issues that
might actually influence their voting
decision without insulting what are
obviously cultural and social
differences and and it would be great to
see other candidates do as good of a job
at it I've not seen any of the top-tier
Democratic candidates do as good of a
job at it as I've seen Elizabeth Warren
do